hello and welcome to this video playing
max power with black and we get this not
very exciting opening the college system
its response to my invitation to many
interesting lines this was chosen but ok
it's perfectly reasonable for white so
he can definitely play this so what's
the deal let's let's go here one idea of
black setup here is to make some
pressure potentially only five if he
decides to do that yeah here tonight eh
five is an interesting try there's some
funny things say if he goes if I have
this night f4 blundering the piece one
light g3 blundering the exchange the h3
ISM is a mistake in this position I
think interesting would be if it takes
on d 59 f for Queen you form f5 yes your
twins material I think yeah so here you
can go now g3 I guess and think for a
moment 93 yep can do that but I think
there's not more than this actually if I
have remember correct layer
this is the the best way to do it and
now I have to take this and I'm happy to
have pocketed the two bishops enter nice
Center porn the epod so I'm not winning
anything but it's nice it's nice to play
yeah my development is not that
brilliant but i hope i can afford those
moves and I'm not overlooking something
[Music]
my aide rook is not protected if I get
in Bishop is six roop the aid f5 that
that would be a kind of yeah that would
be fantastic ready but it's not clear I
can yeah this is a good one this is a
good move
[Music]
94 f5 going back and Bishop e7 I hope
I'm not being overly ambitious here
[Music]
didn't do it
hmm five looks attractive though I
wonder if you can take on age six and
this is the kind of thing that should
not work but he's still my plane let's
let's think about this I can also put
the night on these heavenly and then
that's not a bad move now f5 is on the
agenda and I prevent night c4 I kind of
like this Bishop age 695 it's now
completely out of it out of the picture
yeah not bad look at wow really so 96
you go to h5 snow let's go let's um
let's play straightforward chassis 96 ok
tween age five
I can take this intermediate move I
think
Jesus that gets kind of crazy to double
check you double check is pretty hard to
meet so no go to seven then check
so cannot do that I can just go to e7
there's nothing wrong with that I think
but how do I actually extinguish this
this play like look at four maybe or
something if he has to know it makes
perfect sense he cannot move the night
easily as afterwards hanging damn it I
should have at least try to figure out
what this move does time morning check
check
[Music]
losing this game is amiss business such
a shame chant oh my god this is such a
shame
Queen a five wins probably other things
win as well check yeah how unnecessary
is a gem unbelievable completely
incorrect or [ __ ] that sacrifices check
check
check so we found a winner after all
Quinn evade okay great great so some of
this game could check its not finding
mates check you can check time ok where
the position is winning black resides
Jeff that was bad maybe I should not
play a 55 ish over 6 is indeed not that
easy to play know what stuff is enough
Quincy sixes tangents move just
controlling e-form convenience play G
for him this is also shouldn't work I
mean it really shouldn't yeah check I
mean I give give give up time yet well
before doesn't help him all that much
but now here please I should really
think about at least a little bit what
his idea should be I mean rook g1 and
not exactly difficult because what else
is there yeah and yeah this is this is
just not not cleared or maybe it's it's
bad for me and whatever 27 wins
but it was also unnecessary to actually
get there I mean the here I can making
Chetniks here's chapter king age that
wasn't even winning Wow can't double
check but it's not made yeah okay check
yeah I made it he didn't find the maid
but ok I'm lost anyway yeah but well I
should probably not not even allow this
this bishops Bishop takes this is this
position is so absolutely terrible for
height if I if I just continue with
normal news yes we King badly positioned
pieces and on and on and on queen is
offside and so on it's probably a lot
easier or Bishop t5 or some gym okay
thanks for watching